this next story has sort of been
forgotten because a so-called catch and
kill contract was in place and we'll
talk about that and what that means but
we may be able to get the details of a
child that Donald Trump fathered with a
housekeeper at Trump World Tower you
might remember that a while back a
doorman at Trump World Tower named Dino
sardine or says 'add in I'm not exactly
sure how he pronounces his last name
the doorman supposedly had a story about
Donald Trump fathering a housekeepers
child but we didn't hear more about it
because American media Inc also known as
a.m. I made a deal with the doorman to
prevent him from being able to talk
about it and the reason that a love
child or an illegitimate child whichever
term we prefer I don't love some of
these terms they're certainly not the
most politically correct terms that
that's for sure some people would call
it a child out of wedlock although who
likes the sound of that in any case the
contract that the doorman signed
specifically says quote source shall
provide ami with information regarding
Donald Trump's illegitimate child it now
appears that the contract which
prevented the doorman from telling the
story is no longer in place or will soon
be taken out of operation and that he
may soon be able to speak freely about
this his lawyer is now saying mr saye
dean hopes the truth will come out in
the very near future at this time Donald
Trump having an illegitimate child has
not been independently confirmed however
it would be very odd to include a
reference to it in a private contract if
it were bogus but I want to get to the
important thing why would it matter if
Trump fathered a so-called illegitimate
child it's similar to why would it
matter if Trump was regularly throwing
around the n-word when talking about
black people I don't care about the
child itself if indeed it's a true story
what I do care about is Donald Trump's
behavior as a bully and his use of hush
money or contracts to silence people
either directly or through his friends
at companies like am i I care about the
constant hypocrisy of his voters who
claimed he was the Family Values
candidate despite the infidelity and now
potentially a love child
Trump won remember
the white evangelical Christian vote by
a huge margin and they are all
hypocrites or liars more likely who
don't actually care about so-called
family values I also do care about the
kid right because it's possible that
this kid doesn't even know Trump is his
dad and he may be about to figure it out
and who knows what that's going to be
like for him him or her I guess we don't
know the gender as far as the truth of
the story we don't know there are people
at ami who were involved in or at least
knowledgeable about the Haj contract and
at the time that it was signed they were
skeptical about the truth of the
lovechild claim but we know that this
was a big enough deal that ami and Trump
wanted to get this deal done so that the
doorman wouldn't tell the story if it's
completely unbelievable they don't pay
the money right like they say go ahead
and say whatever you want people are
going to ignore you if I said I know of
a Donald Trump love child nobody's gonna
pay me money for that because there's no
reason to think I would have specific
knowledge of that the fact that they
signed the contract suggests at least
some people in a position of power
thought that it might be real the
doorman eventually took a polygraph test
which didn't indicate deception but at
this point our polygraphs even if any
value I don't think that they are from
from what I know whether or not this
story is true and is ultimately proven
there are sort of four to six major
irons in the fire right now any of which
would make the next week a massive news
week and I'll be on vacation by the way
which is listen if you want massive news
just have me schedule a vacation because
without fail every time I go on vacation
massive news breaks and I'm not able to
cover it but the good news for you is
you'll be in good hands with multiple
guests hosts covering and then I will be
joining you from a very special project
I'll be working on at a university in
France on the business of independent
media that I'll be working on but more
about that in September no more to say
about it at this time
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is brought to you by the war of awards
war of awards is kind of like video
Game Awards for the people and by the
people if you've ever watched a video
game awards show you've probably thought
they got it wrong at least once that's
because they weren't listening to you
and that's what wore of awards wants to
do you can get your favorite games on
the awards radar by voting at war of
awards org where you can tell the world
which games should win if you're
watching this on YouTube used the link
under this video to join their discord
server show off your gaming savvy by
predicting award winners to challenge
your friends to see who knows the gaming
industry best we're at war of awards org
voting takes place all year long giving
you the chance to change your mind as
new games are released you'll also get
notices about live events where you can
debate your gaming peers and make your
case for why your favorite game deserves
a shelf full of trophies the war of
awards it's not an awards show it is an
awards show down vote now at war of
awards org